my question is how will Diggle reenlist
ena affect his relationship with his
friends and family when he gets back to
Star City well flash paradox will have
something to do with some of diggle's
reality if you follow what's happened on
lash
he made some changes to a timeline it
will affect Diggle to some degree was
that a spoiler I don't know you just
told us that the flash finale is going
to affect the timeline on arrow yes
that's a spoiler oh really not really
not really everyone's ever because your
panel is not till tomorrow
everyone's x mark like a million people
come to me and like hey is the flash
thing gonna affect you has a flash thing
gonna split you so how does it affect
his family yes it affects his family in
a very very personal way there's a lot
going on with Diggle this season and yes
it affects his family directly oh thank
you
so Brandon you've been on arrow the
flash legends David you have been on
arrow and the flash any chance that we
might see you at some point showing up
on Legends yeah it's kind of like in
this in the Berlanti universe is like
we're all are kind of connected and is
there's so much intersection right so
yeah you know I'm looking forward to
being on Supergirl I don't know if
Diggle will be on Supergirl but I'm
looking forward to that because wrong
what's wrong with my show your show is
awesome but uh I'm looking forward to
the reaction yeah Diggle will have when
you see Supergirl oh yeah yeah
definitely and for you guys because of
the three shows that you've you know
you're part of do you know - does each
show have like a specific type of fan
base can you say like can you tell like
oh they must be an arrow pen oh they're
legends you know they're I don't think I
can tell the tell tell the fans apart
based on but but I think they're
definitely appeal to certain segments
different segments of audiences hmm um
flash tends to trend a little bit
younger audiences I think arrow
I gotta get it right all right not as
young our show I'm our shows kind of
runs the game and I guess I don't know I
don't know I think yeah hmm watches and
Brandon lot of you it actually just
became a Lego minifigure oh my god you
guys realize that they're giving out
they have the exclusive here at the Lego
booth on the convention floor of the
Brandon Ralph as Adam minifigure and
that is for you it is actually the Adam
made to scale awesome yeah so what's
that light look mom this is a complete
surprise I had no idea that this was
this this was happening that's okay you
won't get any money from that either I
tweeted it I tweeted them I tweeted them
earlier today and said that the face
wasn't quite right the suit but the suit
looked pretty good into Legos nice all
right and David dig ended the season
leaving team arrow and we spoke with
Marc Guggenheim and he told us in the
official TV Guide comic-con issue that
dig might not be in the military for
long right can you tell us anything
about what kind of trouble he gets
himself into can I tell you what kind of
trouble gets himself into them I don't
know but I do know that arrow is gonna
save his ass okay
all right cuz always happens you know I
don't know that he's overseas he's on a
mission there's there's big try my don't
know if he's as big as damian darhk--
but um there's a big heavy coming arrow
this year thankfully is kind of getting
more back to the kind of nuts and bolts
fighting a little bit away from I think
the big nukes and mankind things like
that so we'll see how big was involved
in them and now the defense of your show
are very verbal they even had a lot to
say about digs Spartan helmet when it
was unveiled because it did seem to be
any responsible use of his eye space how
do you do yeah how do you deal with the
massive amount of like tweets and
comments in like they just the the glut
of fan reactions very
carefully I don't know I mean I love it
you know I think all of us at some point
we're all kind of actors wanting for
work and now we have these great shows
on television 12 seasons for God's sakes
we can all be so lucky
so um I mean is great the fans have been
great of arrow and legends and Supergirl
and flash so there's just no complaints
the helmet though there will be a new
helmet this season there you go yeah so
all the mag Negro jokes this is the true
thing I'm so glad you said that but I
couldn't
you